[Música]
en el mundo mediático de la moda hay
pocos documentales de calidad dedicados
a ella hoy hablamos sobre una película
que cuenta la historia de una magnífica
aventura la de una boutique que se
mantuvo en pie en las calles empedradas
de la gustan o no ve de parís durante 20
años del 97 al 2017 cole fue sobre todo
una historia familiar con la ruso
qué más se puede decir
si no hay nada que añadir soy la gerente
general de la compañía
estoy principalmente a cargo del
personal y de la administración de la
tienda
yo estoy a cargo de las compras de las
exposiciones de la programación de
eventos y de muchas otras cosas
colette fue la primera conceptos de
parís 700 metros cuadrados divididos en
tres pisos un bar donde se servían 80
tipos diferentes de agua mineral una
librería música moda para hombres y
mujeres sus elecciones al igual que las
vitrinas se cambiaban cada semana y
también había una galería de arte y un
área de belleza donde pacen una
excepción cucsh nuestra idea nuestro
punto de partida era el ser humano
tratar de darnos cuenta de lo que había
detrás de esta institución y así se nos
dio la oportunidad de contar la historia
de esta diversidad tanto entre los
empleados como entre los clientes porque
una tienda en la rue saint honoré con
tanta diversidad especialmente en los
años en los que fue fundada en el 97 en
este caso eso no existía ese modelo fue
copiado por supuesto o al menos se
extendió y se hizo más democrático pero
no lo era así en ese momento
este parque de pax
[Música]
y fue una de las pocas personas que
siempre me aceptó nunca me dio la
espalda cuando lo piensas soy una
celebridad negra estadounidense
heterosexual todas las cosas que la moda
no era cuando llegue a parís
no sé si ustedes escucharon hablar de
ese episodio en la historia de la
cultura callejera pero en una 'fashion
week' en verano hice el lanzamiento de
un libro que se convirtió en una pelea
en colette estaba ahí sabrok y su grupo
y para mí fue como una onda de choque
porque fue dentro del college estalló
una pelea
[Música]
[Aplausos]
como la vida
[Música]
para mí fue como esto es la juventud
esto es una foto instantánea de la
energía de la nueva generación
[Música]
sara del man lleva 20 años viajando por
todo el mundo y no solamente debido a la
semana de la mula sino también en busca
de joyas artísticas
la fuerza de esa red era decirse que
viajaba cuando veía algo el viaje no era
un viaje en el tiempo en ese momento
cuando uno iba a tokio le llevaba dos
años de ventaja a todo lo que pasaba en
el mundo
[Música]
desconocías ahora cuando fui a la
presentación de mi colección en japón me
impresionó su profundo conocimiento del
diseño de prendas ella entendía muy
rápido no necesitaba explicarle por qué
o con qué propósito si yo había diseñado
tal detalle de tal manera ella lo
entendía inmediatamente me impresionó
mucho
[Música]
en consideró que köhler sirvió de
vitrina para un gran número de productos
y marcas japonesas un fashion de aquel
barco de marín y no sólo en parís aunque
escoletes tan parecida que te van a
gustar se callen sino en todo el mundo
hero mata todo como temas
colletti su hija sara inventaron las
colaboraciones productos creados
conjuntamente por marcas de lujo y de
streetwear en cantidades limitadas yo
pienso que lo que más me fascinó fue en
meses y después que se te porque para mí
era un gran sueño acción y entonces el
día que sara me dijo que íbamos a hacer
eso me pareció completamente fantástica
colette mona mole firme no estará en
cines o en televisión sólo está
disponible en internet en streaming para
ser alquilada o comprada
es muy asequible era lo que realmente
queríamos porque ese era también el
espíritu de colette era ofrecer
experiencias que fueran los más
asequibles posible cuando fuera posible
así que el alquiler cuesta cuatro euros
y la descarga 8 es realmente asequible
se llama accesible hoy colecta está
disfrutando de una merecida jubilación
sara continúa con sus actividades de
consultoría y el desarrollo de
colaboraciones a pesar de la pandemia
sigo siendo muy optimista muy positiva
creo que todos recordarán este periodo
de cuestionamientos
donde jon kate lleva a muchos jóvenes
diseñadores que quieren trabajar con
materiales y procesos basados en la
sostenibilidad es autor la
sostenibilidad y espero que la gente
siga leyendo libros en papel escuchando
vinilos música en vinilo
quiero sonar como una buena diciendo
esto pero cosas reales de sus red
colette y sara habían inventado una
nueva forma de ver el mundo y no sólo el
de la moda la película dedicada a ellas
se convierte hoy en una inmensa fuente
de energía para nosotros
[Música]